bonjour lucas vous êtes place de la
bourse point de rendez vous entre autres
des gels et jaune
[Applaudissements]
absolument et vous pouvez voir sur ces
images de didier migaud que la foule
vient juste de se mettre en marche pour
le défilé les revendications de ces
manifestants sont toujours les mêmes
depuis le 12 juillet depuis les annonces
emmanuel macron d'étendre le pass
sanitaires nous on passe sanitaires non
à la vaccination obligatoire pour
certaines professions et non à la
surveillance par qr codes ces
manifestants ils étaient aussi réunies
place de la bourse pour une raison
précise c'est ici que se trouve le siège
de la lfp ils ont un message à faire
passer à la presse qu'ils accusent de
partialité je vous propose d'écouter une
des organisatrices à qui j'ai pu parler
au début de cette manifestation
on a décidé de faire cette manifestation
comme depuis plusieurs mois en fait on
fait déjà pour protester contre la
dictature sanitaire qui est en marche
avec avec l'aide des médias les médias
meanstream c'est pour ça qu'on est ici
devant la fpf
le mot d'ordre de ces manifestants
restent liberté je vous propose d'en
écouter quelques-uns avec qui j'ai pu
parler avant le début de ce défilé
lorsqu'on veut obliger les gens par le
matériel nous obliger à aller le faire
vacciner ça ça me fait encore plus peur
est en fait c'est un bras est encore
plus dans dans l'idée de dire de je
résiste mais pacifiquement mais pas de
violences au boycott du coup les
endroits où on demande le passé a noté
un maximum enfin j'y vais pas il ya
plein de gens qui peuvent pas travailler
ou qui sont contraints
de se faire administrer donc la rn pour
pouvoir travailler c'est une contrainte
parce qu'ils ne le veulent pas donc
c'est ça qui me dérange le plus c'est
qu'on entraves à la liberté travail et
subvenir à ses besoins et voilà on
profite de ça pour contraindre les gens'
je suis pas anti vaccins mais
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on n'a pas assez
de recul et qui a d'autres solutions
et quelque part ben j'ai pas confiance
en
en gommant n'est parole du gouvernement
tout simplement la semaine dernière a
été marquée par une légère baisse du
nombre de manifestants selon les
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur qui
sont très controversés mais aussi selon
le collectif de militants le nombre
jaune mais rien de bien inquiétant
personnage restantes estiment que c'est
tout à fait normal
désormais sur les rentrées pour faire
plier le gouvernement
la place de la bourse à paris où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'animations autour de
vous